des forêts - verte des arbres des 6 me
de leur feuillage la chenille spongieuse
européenne fait des ravages cette année
on les trouve par dizaines accrochés aux
arbres
on n'a pas vu autant d'années passées
non cette année c'est plus remarqué ce
pas mr là sur les roches donc moi ces
skins qui m'étonne ça fait deux semaines
de ce que je vois ça elle s'attaque
particulièrement au boulot et aux
chaînes mais raffole également des
conifères mai prochain ils vont être
encore en vie vous pas pensé qui est
absolument parce que put feuillage pour
les conifères leurs sapins épinettes
c'est plus difficile il peut mourir en
une année cette invasion se voit un peu
partout au québec et ailleurs au canada
la spongieuse à défaut lié près de 600
mille hectares de forêt en ontario en
2020 normalement je ne devrais pas être
pris occupe 1 puisque le phénomène qu'on
observe cette année c'est une
conséquence d'un hiver relativement
cléments avec ses longs poils et ses
points bleus et rouges la spongieuse
n'est pas toxique mais un contact avec
la peau peut causer des démangeaisons
importés en amérique du nord il ya plus
de cent ans par un entrepreneur français
elle s'est implantée de manière
permanente aux etats-unis faute de
prédateurs y aucun même bonne nouvelle
il ya certaines variétés de champignons
qui est apparu dans les dernières années
aux états unis et qui exercent une
prédation sur les spongieux selon
quelques experts il n'y a pas lieu de
s'inquiéter pour le moment puisque le
phénomène est cyclique
mais les changements climatiques
pourraient entraîner des hivers plus
doux et ainsi contribuer à leur
prolifération
ici marc isabelle roche radio canada
montréal